once again please enjoy my latest Conan
videoblog
[Applause]
[Music]
if something we heard with the video I
didn't say it was a good video blah it
didn't look this way at rehearsal all
right let's just go with it screw it
[Laughter]
don't worry about it don't worry about
it we're just gonna go at with it this
way it looks fine actually on my
computer the audience will attest it
looks fine okay
so it's option control 8 I'm 79 years
old and II get over here where's option
asses on I'm 9 this will prove that
we're hip did that fix it no option
that's option command option control 8
no it's not working it's not working
what the hell the show is free ok
they're doing something they're doing
some they took you from blueberry to
lavender
[Laughter]
like an effeminate oompa loompa all
right here we go we're just gonna keep
going cuz what else do I got to do this
whole thing is cuz I was gonna come in
way to make this thing work okay he
wiggled the cord that wiggled it for the
first step this is great
Wow yep this sure really is my bedroom
any guy isn't working yet huh oh it is
I think he put another quarter in
all right we're just started up the
piece I guess yeah and you guys are
right run the opponent's video blog
thing again go go
[Music]
alright Conan O'Brien here just chillin
in my bedroom
chillin in my bedroom okay here's what's
going on in my world March Madness
started today everyone's talking about
the big upset where UAB won yeah listen
to this UAB that's what I say to Abbey
when it asked me what it is now it's
time to check in with my buddy Andy hey
Conan hi hey Andy
so Andy would even up - oh you know I'm
still totally obsessed with that HBO
show the jinx you know about that creepy
killer guy Robert dirt yeah that kinda
makes my skin crawl he's really scary
yeah and the thing about this guy is
that he's really rich and really sneaky
he got arrested but I bet he could just
escape and that means he could pretty
much be anywhere you think he could be
anywhere in absolutely anywhere I don't
think he could be anywhere
[Music]
[Applause]
I think he's gone now
but he's gone or is he what next segment
is called animals with emotions it's
voice-activated voice-activated yeah
check out this fish this fish is excited
he just say 15% on his car insurance in
15 minutes hey about that here's a
baboon he's excited one of his
co-workers just microwaved some fish in
the office kitchen yeah here's a
squirrel who just watched the season
finale of Empire and he's like oh no
cookie didn't
here's a seal just saw Fifty Shades of
Grey with his mom here's a lemur who
just saw Fifty Shades of Grey by himself
I love this TV show The Slap about the
guy who slaps his kid he just slaps kids
everywhere that's what he does kind of
his profession anyway I love it so much
I've decided to write a song about it
and make a music video - I call it the
slap a musical remix exclusive world
premiere instant class this.left a
musical remix exclusive world free
variously classic we're adults talk to
you you listen to what they're saying
yeah why are you swinging the bat at
Rocco like that
[Music]
crap
[Music]
cut it out Andy knock it off That's not
me I'm right here wait if you're here
who's at the door
just confused
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you
you